[موسيقى]
اكثر من اربعين فنانا من ثلاثه عشره دوله
عربيه صعدوا على المسرح في ليله واحده
تكريما للفنان السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل
قبل اكثر من 22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن
من عطائه الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
عشاقه في السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي
المهمه في الفن السعودي اذا جينا نؤرخ
للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني فنؤرح من
عند طلال مداح
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايه هيئه
الترفيه السعوديه بحضور الالاف من
الجماهير التي ما زالت تردد اغنيه الراحل
حتى يومنا هذا ومن مختلف الاعمار
سلمت علاج الشيخ فطار بيه واتحادي فكان
يحسبني ولد عبد المحسن ال الشيخ الدعم
الاتحاد كان غلبان وقاعد يضحكوا حضني
اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه بالعود بهذا العود
اللي احتفظت ابو 22 سنه وهو عذرا استاذ
طلال
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وقدمت فيه
حنين
السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ الذي قدم
قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم السعوديه
والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه وهو ما
قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا
وعربيهم بلدكم اليوم في تكريمه
[موسيقى]
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكلن يطلع من عندي ما حد يكلمني
يعني اكون من ثاني
صرخه
[موسيقى]